d'accord, j'ai besoin d'une égratignure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je suis un scientifique, donc bien sûr, je veux
essayer de soutenir la science le
processus scientifique chaque fois que je le peux et puisque je n'étudie pas
les virus  Je me sentais un peu inutile ces
jours-ci, donc j'avais l'impression que c'était un moyen très simple
pour moi de soutenir la cause
ouais c'est pourquoi je suis ici et je suis excité
[Musique]
Je pense que vous ne pouvez jamais exclure complètement tout
risque substantiel mais je  pense que vous devez
je suppose que nous marchons et croyons en ces
choses, vous devez avoir confiance en ce qu'ils
que le travail a été fait du mieux qu'ils
peuvent et savoir que la cause est importante
pour que ma femme soit pleinement consciente que mon fils
pense juste que je  est-ce que papa allait travailler
aujourd'hui et je suppose que je vais travailler pour
différents travaux différentes choses dans tout
[Music]
personnellement, j'ai un degré élevé de
confiance à propos de ce vaccin parce que
c'est une technologie que j'ai utilisée avant bien
sûr nous  devons le tester bien sûr, nous
devons obtenir les données des humains, nous avons
utilisé la technologie pour fabriquer de nombreux
vaccins différents
[Musique]
nous le testons dans l'étude d'efficacité interne
et nous devons savoir si cela
fonctionne, il n'y a absolument aucun  suggestion que
nous allons commencer à utiliser ce vaccin
dans une population plus large avant d'avoir
démontré qu'il fonctionne réellement et
arrête d'infecter les gens par le
coronavirus
[Music]
[Applause]